all right we are here with the lovely
Tiffany Smith this is so awesome to get
to interview you want a red carpet I
love it but I'm like but I love it but
this is the this is the thing you've
worked so hard on you know you were so
great as a host doing the thing but
they're like acting I always know was
something that you really wanted to do
and man you really like did it got
yourself that I mean that Lifetime movie
but hearing Megan oh now that got a
little bit of distance from it how can
you talk about what that experience was
like and how you still feel about
literally felt like grad school for
acting because I got to do you know
there was love scenes I got married I
got in fights I had a baby there was
animals so I literally did where's done
sequence so I did everything that I
think you can do in one movie and then
we did an awesome press tour which was
so much fun I feel like I learned a lot
in a really short amount of time we shot
in a month and then I was doing press
for like a half a month later maybe
three weeks later and then now it's just
kind of get back to the audition grind
and still doing hosting because I love
it so much so finding that balance you
host the Saturn Awards podcast talk to
me about that so Steven Glickman and I
co-host the live from Saturn podcast
which was so much fun because we're both
geeks and we balance each other out
really well because a lot of the stuff I
know a lot about he's like oh I know a
lot but not as much as Tiffany doesn't
the same thing for me
but we had on Harvey from what we do in
the shadows Dean Devlin came on Robert
or see John August so we had and then we
had Cameron cuff Zach Levi so we had
everybody kind of across the board and
talking about their experience with the
Saturn Awards and why they love like
genre and it was awesome because it's
just friends talking with friends you're
here at the Saturn Awards so much going
on geek wise nerd wise what are you
watching out for here tonight at the
award show I just I just have heard this
is my first time ever being at the
Saturn Awards so I've heard that it's
one of the most fun award shows so I'm
just pumped to be there be around my
friends enjoy you know I used to Tyler
hosting I love her so I'm so excited to
see what she's gonna do and then I no
matter who wins like honestly you know
me I watch all this stuff I love all the
stuff so to me it's like everybody who
got nominated I'm not nominated so I can
say this with all like 100% honesty but
it doesn't matter to me who but because
I feel like they're all such
shows and movies and actors so I'm just
excited to be here speaking of acting
what are you working on now what have
you just finished what's going on in
your world right now so I just shot an
episode of a series called Liza on
demand with Liza Koshi who I love and it
was really fun to go from you know Harry
and Megan to doing comedy and I just
finished shooting another project but I
can't quite talk about yet but I will
say it definitely is a show that would
be within the Saturn Awards world yes so
that should be an out soon and what do
you got what else have you got coming up
next besides that he just jumping into
the other host except just acting and
hosting I still do stuff with DC daily
and DC all-access so the next thing I'm
doing is I'm gonna do the junket for the
Joker which I'm really excited to see it
and then get to talk with the actors
it's really cool to get to kind of
balance both sides and talk to the
actors now having a little bit of a
little bit more acting experience and
talk with them about their projects and
stuff so I'm really excited for that the
collider is going to cheer you on every
step of the way you know that thank you
to come back all the time you're never
gonna be rid of me and we shouldn't be
you're the best thank you so much